bonsoir à tous bonsoir si vous nous
rejoignez vous savez toujours le début
du live
a donc pour l'écho sur le début lève on
est chauds lait sur les tests sont mais
un petit peu de temps
n'hésitez pas dans le système des
activités classiques modernes et bien si
vous voyez bien l'écran donnez moi votre
envergure ça fait toujours ça me fait
toujours rire
qui on va passer un petit bout de soirée
ensemble s'est vite addictif
vous avez dit on sait pas su trouver la
bonne nouvelle pourrait finalement on
est encore là
donc voilà n'hésitez pas à vous dire
dans le chat si vous êtes là ou pas
normalement j'ai essayé parce que
j'apprends tous les jours j'ai essayé de
faire
est d'utiliser un bot vous allez me dire
c'est ça marche on va essayer par
exemple quelque chose
si je fais ça est ce que ça fonctionne
ou pas
peut-être pas peut-être que je suis en
quarts pas pas assez bon on essaye
maintenant mais forcément six jeux cij
actifs pas ça va pas marcher
hop là
m
bonsoir à tous bonsoir si vous arrivez
on essaye
à superbe superbe ça fonctionne nous
voilà maintenant vous avez des petites
commandes qui vous permettent de donner
les
des liens avec notre site donc là vous
avez directement à voir le site
envergure qui s'affiche vous pouvez
aussi avoir nos comptes twitter le
compte twitter d'envergure le compte
twitter personnel ça permet de gagner du
temps dans le cochon georges frêche en
live et puis voilà toujours sympa je
vais laisser le temps aux gens d'arriver
et puis on va pas partir tranquillement
n'hésitez pas à me dire si vous avez fut
un match s'il ya un prospect avait
découvert six voilà peu importe les
changements trop
on prend le temps de s'installer
j'ai un petit peu les réseaux en même
temps
bon pour le programme d'aujourd'hui je
vais commencer
vous expliquez vous qu'on va parler on
va parler d'un joueur qui a attendu pour
du premier tour parfois annoncé lottery
pick et sinon le top ne trouve plus
souvent dans le top 30 c bénédicte
mathurin bénédicte mathurin
canadiens dont on a déjà parlé l'an
dernier ben notre benji envergure était
très amoureuse de lui et c'est pas parce
que c'était un c'est un compatriote
bonsoir thomas ce que moi tu vois comme
je disais on va pas aller toujours de
bénédicte mathurin qui est un sophomore
sophomore qui joua arizona qui est un
deuxième arrière qui avait fait une
bonne première impression l'an dernier
qu'on avait découvert qui ensuite
enchaîné sur u 19 cet été avec le canada
où il a fait médaille de bronze il joué
entre autres avec eux notre ami caleb
houston le prospect freshman star de
michigan puis il y avait aussi des
bardes qui joue cette année je crois à
crayton et on avait acquis dit le pivot
dr diouf voilà bénédicte mathurin qui
dans une deuxième année et qui répondent
présents qu'ils ont des crous standard
on va voir ça ensemble je vous laisse
encore le temps
d'arrivée on est 7 8 pour l'instant pas
refaire de pouvoir démarrer ensemble
donc voilà ça le programme bénédicte
mathurin et après je vous ai prévu un
petit jeu un petit quiz on va essayer de
tous ensemble à de se refaire une draft
on va prendre la dernière draft en bas
on va essayer de voir si on peut trouver
les 60 joueurs côté drafté en 2021 si on
est bien on a bien gardé en mémoire et
puis voilà tout simplement petit jeu
pour finir et là cette fois ci je vous
dirais vraiment au revoir jusqu'au
vacances et on se retrouve un jeu qu'on
va pas jusqu'au jusqu'à noël et on se
retrouvera passer le réveillon passé les
fêtes de famille pour un nouveau de
nouveaux prospecter de nouveaux films
bon bah écoutez 21h31 vous êtes à leurs
résultats v10 21h30 donc on parle et on
va démarrer tranquillement
on va du coup regardez on les disait le
profil de bénédicte mature ans alors je
vous passe sur le site internet
envergure point ces eaux
ici
là normalement ces affiches
parfait et c'est est-ce que c'est assez
gros vous me dites ainsi vous voyez pas
correctement au niveau des stats la shdm
h en plein écran le livre de mon
téléphone à côté donc ça m'a l'air pas
trop mal bénédicte mathurin
on a un joueur sophomore dix neuf 19 ans
et demi dans 20 ans au moment de la
draft qui d'origine canadienne comme on
l'a dit post 2 postes 3 2 m 01 89 kg une
envergure ans à intéressante du palais
stats les chiffres exacts faudra
attendre peut-être le compagne pour
avoir des chiffres
100% vaincu white qu'est ce qu'on peut
dire on a vouvoyé peut-être sur la photo
ici qu'on a dit un physique plutôt bien
développés il joue du côté des wildcats
d'arizona qui est une équipe majeure de
la pac twelve donc l'impact wave comme
vous dirai
walton c'est la conférence officielle
tunes naim et d'or qui sort des gros
programme arizona ucla oregon
washington wayne state
arizona state encore un autre dernier
nouvel arrêté des programmes de réputé
qui sortent des jours tout chaque année
en nba arizona les derniers mais qu'on
peut aussi t on à chuck greene du côté
de dallas qui malheureusement ne joue
pas sic naji du côté des nuggets qui
joue très très peu pour l'instant mais
qui en projet un développement nico
magnol nicolau manyan quitter rennes les
normes prospects qui finalement est
reparti du côté de boulogne après un
tout début contracte qui a pas été très
concluant avec les warriors et puis un
peu plus anciennes mendiants drayton
laurie markkanen etc terra nova un
programme réputé qu'à changer de coach
cette année elle tient un nouveau coach
qui donc voilà je trouve qu'il fait du
bien meilleur travail en avez chaîne
miller avant et maintenant le nouveau
coach je l'ait pas là sous les yeux mais
voilà on a du changement de temps dans
les bureaux parlons maintenant de
bénédicte mathurin
on voit cette année 18,3 points tous des
statistiques très intéressantes en terme
de points avec un temps de jeu de 31
minutes sur les quarante minutes
possibles antillais
on est à
6,6 rebonds donc on a un joueur qui peut
contribuer au niveau du haut niveau du
robot des deux côtés on voit défensif
offensif un tiers de rebonds offensifs
de tirs 2 rebonds défensifs on est là
c'est qui va nous intéresser pour la
suite aussi deux passes par match mais
aussi deux pertes de balle donc on est
sur un joueur qui est un ratio assistant
nos 20 ans ce qui n'est pas exceptionnel
surtout pour un joueur qui a des
aspirations de créateurs balle en main
on voit que là ya toujours des
difficultés côté défensive on a une
interception pour un match on a zéro
trois blocs dont quelque chose d'assez
anecdotique du boîte et des pourcentages
on attaque on voit que le nombre de tirs
tentés a pratiquement augmenté entre
l'année en la d2 on est à + 5 tirs
tentés par match on peut l'expliquer
avec le départ notamment de james acquis
du jour qui est parti du côté de baylor
le meneur qui prenaient beaucoup de deux
tirs en termes de pourcentages on est à
50 % global qui est correct on est 60 %
à 2 points avec le voit plus de tirs
pris à deux points dont 60% à 2 points
c'est à fait intéressant sachant que le
joueur existe
près du panier mais aussi à mi-distance
faudra garder ça et surtout on voit 3 5
3 points l'an dernier pour 42 % ce qui
était très bon là on double quasiment le
volume 6,2 tirs tentés et toujours une
belle réussite 38% en termes de lancers
francs par contre on est à quatre
lancers francs tentés par match ce qui
n'est pas exceptionnel pour un joueur
aux qualités athlétiques
que sont audi qualité de bénédictin qui
sont les qualités de l'équipe de
bénédicte matures par contre une fois
qu'ils voient sur la ligne il est
efficace ça c'est pour le profil
statistique de base on va regarder un
peu les stats à avancer maintenant
peut-être l'habitude avec moi on regarde
un petit peu de cette avancée pour voir
quels profils on va avoir chaud au
niveau du joueur sur du concret et
ensuite on passe le film pour regarder
ça ensemble
non aucun problème si tu t'inquiètes pas
installe toi on parle de bénédicte
mathurin d'arizona que je pense que tu
connais tu de mal à parler dans la
dernière fois
voilà on va faire du prêtre donne de ce
jour là on fait un seul jour aujourd'hui
ça une session un peu plus courte et on
a un petit jeu derrière un petit quizz
ensemble donc la stalle toi
tranquillement on passe au stade avancé
de bénédicte matures alors on regarde
donc sa charge excusez moi ça mouline un
petit peu on reste dans la campagne de
l'essonne bénédicte mathurin c'est le
plus gros volume de tir de l'équipe i
joue dans son équipe avec du belize
l'occasio la stib ellis qui a un frère
dans l'équipe aussi qui est à
l'intérieur lituanien
un petit peu marqué près du panier qui a
un bon haendel et voilà il joue avec
pierre crise a alors aucun rapport avec
steve kerr entente de famille s'est
jusque là les parents étaient fans de
steve carr d'eau qui sont donnés comme
prénom caire alors à leur fils qui est
un excellent shooteur de gros volumes il
joue avec un o tempo kologo christian
question qu'aux locaux du cou qui est à
l'intérieur que vous allez tous vous
allez sûrement entendu parler dans les
années qui vont suivre est-ce que ça
devrait arriver en nba est aussi d'elle
en théorie qui est un meneur de grande
taille comme moi je les aime qu'on
pourrait aussi retrouver une pièce voilà
plusieurs joueurs professionnels
intéressants mathurin on le voit dans la
répartition des tirs c'est assez proche
de ce qu'on va voir en nba
beaucoup de trois points quasiment la
moitié de ces tirs avec 38 de réussite
et on voit
92% prix en catch and shoot donc c'est
quasiment uniquement du catch and shoot
on n'a pas un jour qui va se créer son
tir on va voir ça dans les dents la
vidéo ensuite
quarante pour cent de ces tirs sont pris
près du cercle donc une répartition vous
avez quasiment tous trois points auprès
du cirque quand il est près du bagne et
on voit excellent finisseur 70 5% et là
on est à moitié de catch and shoot à
moitié en tout cas de finition après une
passe décisive et l'autre moitié c'est
lui qui va dans un rêve secret son écart
ou tout cas se crée un accès au panier
pour finir par lui même quelques tirs à
mi distance très épisodique 14% 26 % de
réussite seulement ça va pas être là
dessus qu'on attend on le voit 27 5% au
niveau de ce ratio qui nous permet de
savoir si le joueur a beaucoup de
lancers francs je dis donc de tirs
tentés moi j'aime bien le mettre en
relation avec le nombre de tir nantais
près du panier donc on voit que c'est un
joueur qui lorsqu'il va au cercle trouve
assez régulièrement des lancers francs
il est efficace
bénédicte mathurin c'est un de ces
joueurs ou l'impression visuelle est
assez différente je trouve de ce que
montrent les statistiques
quand je le regarde
jouer on voit un joueur qui est
très sous avec beaucoup de touché mais
je trouve qu'ils évitent souvent le
contact et qui va pas au bout ou qui va
pas de nom le rentrer dans son défenseur
direct pour dominer
et j'avais l'impression qu'ils avaient
des stades près du panier qui était plus
basse que ça en fait on voit que c'est
quand même un jour qu'il va beaucoup
près du cercle et un peu de mes
distances et qui réussit bien comme quoi
c'est toujours intéressant quand on fait
du scouting repport tout juste qu'on
garde un joueur de pouvoir se fier au
stade aussi pour confirmer ou non une
impression visuelle on va passer du coup
au clip deuxième stick pour les stats
avancées avec des codes couleurs ça peu
sympa
quel site on peut voir ses stats alors
ça s'appelle matt je peux essayer de le
mettre dans le chatt j'essaie de vous
faire ça tout de suite
matt
donc là pour arizona je crois que ce
passe une commande pour ça aussi alors
est ce que j'arrive à faire ça
non bah écoutez je vais le faire je vais
faire sur le côté je vais faire sur le
côté ce qu'on va prendre de petites
secondes
quand tu vois l'url en eau
alors est ce que j'arrive à faire ça ou
pas oui
hop
excusez moi je suis sur deux écrans en
même temps
et voilà
il ya le site envers le club sur le site
envergure vous avez les stats classique
entre guillemets les stats qui sont
liées à pascal bolo référence et / ou
peaux mates vous avez des stades avancés
et il ya le deuxième où peut explorer
qui est ici garrido rien il ya comme ici
avec plaisir le deuxième site qui est
ici ou qu'explorer qui vous donne à peu
près les mêmes informations avec un code
couleur encore une fois qui vous donne
de l'efficacité du joueur par rapport au
reste de la ligue donc on voit que
bénédicte mature ans c'est un joueur qui
par rapport au reste de la ligue est
très et fight plutôt efficace dans le
trois points 38 % c'est la moyenne au
total un code couleur vert un peu
claires par contre on voit que c'est un
joueur qui est très bon par rapport au
reste de la ligue dans la finition près
du panier est très mauvais par rapport
au reste de la ligue dans la finition à
mi distance c'est apprendre aussi avec
des pincettes c'est à dire que
évidemment les intérieurs vont avoir des
stades plus haute est donc un joueur
extérieur
pâtira de ça donc si vous avez un joueur
qui est moyen par rapport au reste de la
ligue essayé deux points à l'extérieur
essayez de vous dire que il ya des
intérieurs qui hausse les pourcentages
là ce qui est très bien c'est qu'on a un
ailier qui au niveau des intérieurs avec
un volume intéressant par rapport au
reste de la haine sied de la première
division maintenant que c'est fait que
c'est dit vous avez un peu un profil on
va regarder du clip on peut regarder ce
que les copains nous disent de
bénédicte match donc vous avez deux ou
trois articles qui ont été écrits sur ce
joueur il y en a un c'est moi qu'il
l'écrit donc j'aimerais vous l'envoyez
parce que ça n'a pas d'intérêt où je
vous fais un peu là l'idée est liée à
surveiller donc il en fait partie là on
a ben
là on à julien pas nous excuser mois
d'août qui est le spécialiste de la pac
twelve qui a regardé
bénédicte mathurin contexte u19 avec le
canada toujours intéressant de regarder
différents contextes
ouais look sip il est frustrant will est
frustrant bénédicte nature d'ailleurs
faut que j'arrête de répéter ce nom je
vais vous faire câble et à force jusque
jeudi de mathurin
il est très frustrant on va regarder ça
dans les clips donc comme vous le voyez
arrière bodybuildé avec des attentes pas
mal pour la coupe du monde donc 16
points 49 % toujours ceux de passe de
faire une perte de balle donc ça dans un
contexte national il y avait les mêmes
défauts il nous dit que c'est un joueur
qui se déplace vite et aux as explosif
qui a d'un tir à trois points dont 2,6
alors là cette année il est très
efficace et un dornier aussi premiers
pas puissant rapide
et in time plus plus plus ça c'est ce
que nous dit julien dans un contexte u19
benoît lelièvre nick baynes chez
envergure nous dit pourquoi est ce qu'il
faut regarder médiatique matures en
cette saison il ya parlé il ya deux mois
c'est parce que c'est un joueur qui peut
être attendu pour la loterie comme il
nous le dit là on se demandait ce qui
peut jouer en pick and roll escale à la
vision nécessaire lui il est assez
inquiet là dessus il écarte de la carte
de la réserve et je suis assez d'accord
avec lui
si on regarde il nous dit qu'il a les
capacités techniques et athlétiques pour
le faire mais pour être l'intégration
jeu donc voilà la partie réserve
il nous est dit que c'est un bon
recruteur là dessus on est d'accord et
il nous parle d'un problème défensif
défensif côté collectif donc voilà ça
c'est la vie des des fans des fans des
fans des mondes d'envergure sur le jour
le joueur est maintenant en outre son
ensemble ou est-ce qu'il est projeté
loterie entrerait loterie fans premier
tour ça dépend pour quoi vous l'achetez
ans et
comment vous croyez lorsque vous achetez
est-ce que vous ajoutez un porteur de
balle dans ce cas là vous allez c'est
peut-être de prendre plus haut parce que
les équipes aiment bien bordé pourtant
de balle et est ce que le joueur est
fait pour ça moi là dessus j'ai des
réserves et on va regarder où est ce que
vous achetez un finisseur d'action
athlétique avec un bon shoot à trois
points dans ce cas-là via un peu moins
de valeur marchande eux puisqu'on est
sur du finisseur et que les équipes
qui sont un peu plus en difficulté dans
le bas de la hadra pain dans le bas de
la nba nous dans le haut de la draft ont
osé d'avoir des créateurs
justement pour avoir du talent sur
lesquels s'appuyer on passe au clip
maintenant donc si vous nous suivez un
petit peu vous savez comment je fais mes
clips je veux je répartis par secteur on
commence par les points forts du jeu ces
points d'entrée en nba et ensuite on va
descendant sur les poils est moins
intéressant au fur et à mesure points
forts points faibles tu prends un peu
après l'autre et entre 18 et 22 ch
steagal moi j'ai pas encore moi j'ai des
tiers pour l'instant j'ai pas encore de
place mais il pourrait cependant c'est
dans ces eaux là peut-être un peu plus
bas ça dépendra aussi de des copains de
d-league et des copains de nba yale et
europe voilà comment est ce que je les
intègre parce que pour l'instant je me
suis beaucoup foutu sur l'année si
j'essaie d'avoir un avis bien bien des
financiers après je m'intéresse aux
autres ligues donc on est parti pour les
clips à leur premier point d'entrée on a
vu tireur 92% cannes cette joute avec
une belle réussite c'est pour moi sa
qualité première pour auterive nba il ya
le numéro zéro pour la qualité de
l'image on est toujours du 480p 720p
donc voilà c'est fait on fait au mieux
pour l'instant nova faut suivre le
numéro zéro on est parti le son est bien
minutes c'est bon alors en plein écran
c'est mieux on se réfère vitesse réelle
et en vitesse ralentie ou la lépi c'est
le début donc vous l'avez lâche une
situation de catch and shoot et moi sont
prêtes le déclenchement il est rapide et
ça fait ficelle
est ce que ça s'enchaîne ou pas oui ça
s'enchaîne c'est pour ces merveilles je
vous la remet au ralenti regardez le
placement on va il se présentait au
niveau du porteur de balle avec les
mains qui vont être prête les mâles sont
prêtes je monte rapidement on est face à
tennessee le tennessee c'est un match
hier donc j'ai pas vous spolier les
résultats et vous voyez que c'était
quand même assez mal embarquée pour
arraisonner tennistique une équipe
sérieuse avec seal numéro un que
l'édiction de leurs prospects très
intéressant
petit meneur
est attendue aussi dans les mêmes eaux
que bénédicte mathurin voilà catch and
shoot trois points ça ça fait ficelle
deuxième situation
alors
bon je sais que tu pourrais pas dû être
là je vais regarder si rapidement au
niveau de ma liste de lecture fait beau
on reviendra après encore une fois ouais
d'accord excusez moi j'vous bascule 5
secondes ma liste de lecture elle a
planté on va la refaire c'est pas grave
on va le faire au pire en individuel
hop là on sera mais comme ça
je vous refais ça rapidement désolé
petit problème technique
tout
ok normalement c'est bon je vous la
remet pardon
en plein écran donc ça c'est le catch
and shoot qu'on a vu juste avant
j'espère que ça va être bon
ok non bon bah ça veut pas tant pis
alors on va se la mettre en individuel
ya pas de souci je sais pas pourquoi il
m'a dégagé ma piste de lecture outils
listes de lecture
up non pas tant pis on va se la refaire
hop alors c'est pas grave on va le faire
comme ça
donc mature ans on est joueur aussi un
joueur qui peut exister sur du 3 points
en transition
alors hop ça c'est bien ça c'est bien ça
c'est bien voilà
donc trois on a mené sur trois pour un
transit ont ils déclenchent directement
avec un peu de suspense un peu de
réussite effet fait ficelle donc c'est
un joueur qui va être efficace dans ce
faisant se fout de jeu là je vous emmène
autres ici transition bis il est ici on
déclenche rapidement on va se la
remettre au ralenti
au niveau de la distance on a un jet ski
et distance nba
ou là ok regardez on est à bien plus
d'un pas derrière la ligne
il est pris en confiance au niveau du
tir le geste est assez propre et si vous
savez que maintenant on s'y fit un peu
moins le déclenchement est rapide
l'élève à lille b l'élévation
et on va faire filoche à trois points
avec une célébration en plus pour
ajouter du sel ça fait toujours plaisir
autre situation de tir extérieur donc on
va être
ici
tout simplement
derrière un écran je récupère la balle
et encore une fois je monte et finitions
vous l'avez compris on a un shooter
fiable qui aime bien ça maintenant pour
avoir un tir pris de longues distances
ici notre ami il est ici catch and shoot
regardez la distance on est vraiment sur
une distance nba
élévation trois points
duncan robinson style ouais alors duncan
robinson c'est plus un instructeur de
twitter de mouvements jeteurs de course
et des dictatures ans pour l'instant il
est plus vraiment de rôle de finition
ya pas vraiment ses courses en fle pied
c'était dans le système d'arizona pour
pouvoir exister là dessus mais les
jeunes qui pourtant des aventures là
pour provoquer des fautes toujours
rempli son île belle élévation knoxy ya
quelqu'un à l'erreur de mettre la
cheville en dessous
il y aura forcément faute maintenant ses
fautes techniques deuxième point avec
bénédicte mathurin fut vraiment que
j'arrête de dire son nom d' si je sais
pas pourquoi je frites à ce point là
ça va être un joueur qui a des qualités
athlétiques et qui peut partir en drive
et finir sa joueur qui a beaucoup de
touches et on va voir ça sur la première
action
annoncée pas ce qui m'a changé le web
c'est ça il m'a changé en fait le nom de
mes de mes fichiers du bonheur du pur
bonheur d'accord très bien
ok y'a pas de soucis
on va aller sur autre chose alors
j'espère que là c'est bon
alors on va tueur du drive main droite
avec une finition flotteurs saint geours
qui es tu vois dans quelle franchise bah
écoute toujours difficile la comm ca de
2 011 sera de réfléchir ensemble à la
fin on finit les clips on essaie de
regarder ça donc on est en drive main
droite et vous allez voir voilà ce geste
là c'est typique bénédicte mathieu on a
un joueur qui a beaucoup de finesse
beaucoup touché qui ne prouve qu'ils
n'aiment pas particulièrement allait
finir fort au contact du défenseur on
est face à michigan mais qui préfère
avec un flotteur se créer son propre
espace est terminée sans que la défense
puisse contester donc là on est main
droite interdit kingson qui comptait ce
cas les bulletins sur son dos et tout en
finesse avec un flotteur je vais
terminer ça vous le voyez au moins deux
trois fois par match
tout
rêve main gauche le temps main droite
donc parler un jour qui peut partir dès
demain ici on va la voir partir main
gauche
et finir à ma droite avec le même
flotteurs donc qu'il est la nôtre imbibé
la dictature en de l'intérêt qui lui
fait la passe on part à ma gauche et je
finis ma droite tout en finesse avec un
petit flotteur on peut se la refaire au
ralenti
khaled hussein au premier plan et cycles
22 très jolie
donc d'elle en théorie qu'il a le droit
de grande taille du belize qui est ici
là l'intérêt qui transmet du coup
mathurin on voit on frise que caleb
houston
annoncé elie brooks ici sur anticipe le
pick and roll côté côté droit donc je
peux partir main gauche
j'ai une contestation qui est ici au
lieu d'aller finir fort en puissance au
niveau du lait apl faire contrer je
préfère quand je suis bénédicte mathurin
en élévation parce que j'ai un très bon
ntem j'ai un très bon contrôle
abdominale et verticale de finir par
dessus le défenseur c'est un contrat
quand c'est bien fait
et ici c'est bien fait la vue tout à
l'heure 70 % de réussite
dans ces actions là nous voyez qu'on
vous parle de rester près du panneau
110% en fait ya beaucoup de gestes tout
en finesse plutôt touché ici je dois
être pas mal de l'ue michael prix
discount à une certaine gouaille j'aime
bien quand un richardson comme queen
teen une personne comme comparaison ça
c'est sympa voilà c'est un joueur qui
est très athlétique mais qui est pas
brut s'est pas ou c'est pas un agresseur
de corps qui valait provoquer des fautes
on va vraiment pas de la fidesz et du
toucher personnellement
personnellement je suis pas hyper fan
des joueurs qui comptent beaucoup sur
leur flotteur en tout 26 j'aime bien les
joueurs qui ont un flotteur dans leur
arsenal mais qu'ils vont être capables
de prendre le dessus physiquement au
niveau collégial parce que je me dis que
si tu peux pas prendre le dessus
physiquement au niveau collégial tu ne
pourras pas le faire en nba donc
intéressante mais frustrant parce que
j'aimerais bien un joueur qui provoque
plus de fautes quand son flotteur est un
peu
son flotteur est un peu en échec et
qu'on a un défenseur long en face de lui
de la même taille et de la même vitesse
il est plus simple sans difficulté
pour un délit c'est un aveu de faiblesse
les flotteurs bas je suis assez je suis
assez d'accord là dessus donc c'est
toujours bien d'en avoir en commun
d'être efficace surtout qu'on est très
efficace comme lui on voit qu'ils
trouvent des fautes je trouve ça a peu
préjudiciable
on le voit dans le démarrage main gauche
pour parler du drive que on a un joueur
qui ne changent pas demain dans son
drive c'est pas important de balle
principale
il ya peu de variations dans le rythme
on est un bon premier pas main gauche ma
droite mais une fois que c'est parti
d'une main je vais pas changer de mains
donc c'est pas un vrai extérieur porteur
de balle voilà on est vraiment je suis
rannou l'udps ailier finisseur qui est
lui c'est d'être un second porteur de
balle et c'est pas pour ça que je
l'achète on va partir sur un autre drive
l'agefi le drachme à droite pas exposé
il vous allez voir que je suis une
défense plus placer une défense qui le
tient un peu mieux et qui ne l'est pas
le flotteur il est un peu plus en
difficulté donc il est là hilal bordeaux
main droite ses explosifs vous voyez là
il est contesté il trouve la faute donc
tous heureusement pour lui trouve la
faute et un bon sabrage on est face à
une équipe northern arizona donc les
béances qui n'est pas une bonne équipe
mais plus 20 mai dans la montée au
niveau du lay up n'a pas une protection
de balle suffisante et sera défenseur
nba la tue moi j'ai peur
mais j'ai peur que ce soit beaucoup plus
difficile pour notre ami matures j'ai
pas dit le prénom miracle en grosse un
potentiel souviennent dit alors voilà
c'est ça qu'on essaie de se poser comme
question lui devant comme important de
balai c'est un peu là il espère qu'ils
aient fait dessus pour le projetant
loterie est ce que ça peut être plus que
ça
je suis pas sûr alors pourquoi mon ait
bottes t'attaques je suis désolé un look
si tu à dieu car en full majuscule frax
parce que les règles à ce nouveau film
vielles personnes je le rappelle donc
t'inquiète pas tu survis ce que rien
voilà là dessus problèmes de finition
mais on trouve la faute donc à
surveiller
maintenant
sûr on a vu que c'était un joueur qui
pouvait attaquer le sert qui pouvait
prendre les trois points est ce que
c'est un joueur qui peut passer parce
que là dessus encore une fois lui il a
essayé de se vendre on a vu deux passes
décisives par match 2 pertes de balle on
va regarder
première
action on va être sûr
pour tard de balle tel rôle je pense
il est il est ici voilà qui tiennent
roll et on va cliquer no look prada
l'intérieur va pas faire un pas
directement mais ça on s'en fiche un peu
c'est la vision de jeu vous voyait qu'on
a un joueur qui peut partir d'un droit
de passer une main et manipulations
visuel je ne vais pas regarder le
défenseur là les mâles sont prêtes pour
déclenché à trois points il ya un petit
écran je viens
petit écran qui se met ici je vais
attaquer au niveau du cirque la défense
elle est placée
est tout de suite
je viens sortir sûr de l'intérêt à trois
points sans nba vous avez un shooter
je sais pas dans le corner alors
forcément stephen curry mais peu importe
je parle et qui vante à leurs tarifs car
land la ja ficelles up alors là une
bonne défense et voilà ça on est prêt si
les flash chez
chez notre ami matures on voit qu'il est
capable de faire ça globalement il ya
beaucoup de passes qui sont
bien entendu sonner on voit qu'ils
essaient de faire des efforts mais la
finition n'est pas encore là au niveau
de la dé façon trop basse trop rapide
trop tu vois là il a fait un passeur qui
apprend
on voit ici alors vitesse réalisé la
passe à une main tout simplement moi
j'aime bien les passeurs qui peuvent
passer à une main et finir avec un viol
à ce tube est lisse et une belle lecture
de jeu par m au ralenti on voit tube
ellis qui va aller dans l'accident le
centre qui a pas être couvert par la
zone
est tout de suite allé le trouver par
dessus la défense
et je vais trouver un panier facile qui
va avec la faute donc là dessus
et là dessus on a on a des flashs
positif on le vend beaucoup comme un
rôle plus plus plus 6 à son prochain
c'est tous les jours autour du top 10
alors voila apres c les goûts et les
couleurs de chaque franchise moi je
pense que l'erreur c'est de le draft et
pourant un porteur de balle principal en
fait remportant deux balles de pick and
roll passeur et c'est vous et l'egypte
est en galère pour moi c'est pas ça
c'est plus ça a fini sans direction qui
peut dépanner sur un peu de portée de
balle et qui va t on toujours en
développement
si toi tu les chatons de loterie bah
tant mieux et c'est la franchise elle a
la bonne idée qu'elle draft dans le bon
contexte honoré avec la bonne carte
d'identité tant mieux j'ai pas envie
d'avoir une ligne et walker j'ai pas
envie d'avoir
là encore je veux pas que tu as tu
retrouves sur les spurs mais joshua
primo pour moi c'est la fausse bonne
idée s'ils veulent en faire un bonheur
donc voilà drafté pour les bonnes
raisons passeur fonctionnel en
transition
on voit ici alors je vais vous la mettre
en vitesse réelle c'est tout bête
tout de suite on va cliquer la balle et
stagne pas dans les mains et on a un
shooter caire christ à qui pierre qui a
un excellent tireur à trois points pour
elle et punir
dans le corner et on célèbre avec le
copain alors là ça rentre pas mais voilà
c'est un joueur qui va pas stagner la
balle qui peut prendre rapidement une
décision tout de suite je quitte pareil
des fleuves qui font un théâtre pour un
joueur qui s'inclut dans une équipe
collective
autre passe hop passe transit pareil
tout bête
alors je vous la remet depuis le début
pour vous la voyez bien ça va vite donc
tu belissa la balle qui glisse
transmediale retransmettre tout
simplement
vitesse réelle
tube elissa là bas je retransmets et on
finit chose tout bête il ya des joueurs
qui peuvent 180 défense on a fait cas
les bleus via quels il ya deux jours
qu'elle est blog n'est encore trop
d'actions il va s'est encastré dans la
défense voilà que cela m au ralenti et
ensuite on passe à l'action suivante je
lis bien il ya deux options terry à
tubes ellis et je finis
maintenant y perdre de voix comme je
vous ai dit perdre de ballons par match
alors soit parce qu'il va se la faire
prendre dans les mains soit parce qu'il
va faire une passe trop difficile pour
lui pour l'instant il est encore en
développement
on va regarder
quatre jours ça peut être maintenant
dans tout ce qui va être les démarquages
alors mettre ma clé enfin ma playlist
elle a été cassée donc je suis désolé
une fan de loterie jour de complément
ouais pourquoi pas pourquoi pas assez ça
peut être du mois je les géants loterie
pour l'instant oasis moody oasis me dit
moi je l'avais bien plus haut je pensais
qu'il partait à washington
non je vous dis des bêtises parce qu'ils
partent à sacramento il a glissé c'est
une aubaine pour nos amis de golden
state me disent vous dis mais qui pour
lui est un sou il dit et qui aussi a été
un peu vendu comme important de bol
potentiel en ailier et moi j'y crois pas
du tout je trouve qu'il a un contexte
parfait pour exister comme un chêne
bâtir quelque chose comme ça on va
regardant les cut alors qu'elliott
management d'un athlète
j'ai l'âme en plein écran si ça veut ça
veut c'est parfait en vitesse reste
toujours plus intéressant pour une
première découverte on va enlever les
pixels le temps que la vidéo elle change
merci bien alors il est où il est là que
sont bordeaux là au pardon hop je veux
que tu ais je fini fort près du panier
voilà là dessus aussi jus bien plus
optimiste pour notre ami
notre ami mathurin 4 lille de fond là
dessus du pour exister belle passe de la
série on va finir fort près du panier en
hauteur en plus j'ai un boeing time donc
je vais pas pouvoir me faire arrêter je
vais pouvoir contrôler mon geste en
l'air et terminer avec efficacité on a
d'autres actions en cut si jamais
mon enquête ne conclut pas n'est pas
conclue avec un dunk g1 haendel
suffisant et du toucher pour proposer
autre chose alors toujours ses pixels d
de l'as pardon que dans laxe je suis pas
trouvé mais j'ai un seul petit spin move
chemin à gauche et je fais avec un
flotteur - droite encore une fois le
petit flotteur on se le ralenti notre
garder le cap dans laxe cela passe par
oumar ballo qui est pas transmises on
peut dire que c'est ballot assez pour la
blague donc là il ya une passe qui a été
ratée par oumar ballo dans laxe tant pis
je me repositionne
ici je suis tout seul
alors hop je récupère le ballon hop je
suis main gauche donc je mets ma main
faible
petit spin move ma droite jean rhume le
défenseur et parme ont touché petit
flotteur avec dream time on voit qu'ils
restent longtemps en l'air et je termine
près du panier donc là-dessus pareil ça
quelque chose que j'aime beaucoup chez
lui c'est un finisseur et c'est pas
juste un bunker dans lequel on n'est pas
sur dur
derrick jeunes juniors on n'est pas sûr
du gpat où gamin exemples comme ça de
délier dunker un peu un peu limité on a
un joueur qu'il a quand même dû toucher
tête du drive du dribble pour pouvoir
exister autrement qu'être ligne de fond
alors on n'a qu'à détente sèche donc on
a un joueur qui a une belle détente
sèche j'ai pas les mesures peut-être que
que ben les aurait donc ici il est la
vitesse réelle
je prends dans ligne de fond la
passerelle est au sol tant pis je
remonte très vite et je suis joueur une
détente sèche assez explosive assez
verticale pour pouvoir exister et finir
fort près du panier sans que faire
contesté pour ça aussi je vous dis je
suis assez frustré par le joueur c'est
parce qu'on voit qui est la dea et des
vraies capacités athlétiques et que très
souvent il est trop dans la petit
périphérique urbain qui rhône plus
dedans pour trouver plus de fautes donc
on leur fait voilà je lis des marquages
ligne de fond
et je remonte et on ne m'arrêtera pas de
classe et ziegler qui qui pendant la
contestation
sans réussir enfin dernier cut ici
encore une fois la pâte à mettre passe
directe
donc on est en vitesse réelle je suis
ici contre la même équipe tennessee cut
je suis patient et je peux trouver la
faute derrière
alors c'est celle là
donc regardez là je récupère la balle a
passé les patins croyait de la part de
dell en théorie je vois que j'ai
santiago vers santiago vescovi sur mon
dos la fuye carson qui est ici je vais
être patient on voit au niveau des
appuis on prépare la détente sèche il
tombe sur mon dos et tombe dans la
feinte et je remonte derrière je suis
conscient qu'il ya contact pour pouvoir
faire deux lancers francs pour faire
siffler l'arbitré dont klaus un joueur
qui peut être aussi en efficacité hors
nba
est ce que j'ai un petit truc oui ce que
j'aime bien
hop là
si vous entendez d'écriture derrière
c'est mon plus grand qui réclame à
manger
c'est un ailier sein des ligues qui va
aussi pouvoir poser des écrans et crée
un décalage donc là et si on échoue une
situation avec deux écrans premier écran
qui vient placer où je fais je garde
bien le défenseur dans l'écran je crois
que ces conditions de l'or qui se fait
arrêter ici et derrière je peux me
proposait il sort de l'écran non le voit
qui est là une situation de pick n pop
totalement ouvert alors raté par le
porteur de balle je crois que c'est
pierre qui racle la passe et voilà on a
un joueur qui peut aussi loin du ballon
posé des écrans peut-être sur un truc
une citation de pick and pop sur un
poste 3 poste 4 de petite taille
athlétique ça peut ça peut plaire à
beaucoup d équipes donc globalement
forcément un joueur qui peut
qui peut se développer dans plusieurs
domaines moi je le préfère en finition
exclusif soit trois points soit est ce
que j'ai un bon premier pas et que je
suis assez athlétique jure un démarquage
où on vient close up et j'attaque le
cercle ou bien sûr vraiment il de fond
avec un dunk
pour le dribble on a vu que ça un
dribble avec un bon premier pas mais un
dribble assez linéaire sur le sur la
main droite toujours la main gauche peut
pâtir des deux mamies change pas de
direction une fois qu'il est parti et
changent pas de vitesse nos plusieurs il
va pas ralentir ou accélérer dans son
drive est sur quelque chose pour
l'instant de mono vitesse
exemple dans le drive en comparaison il
a kokoro et je dis pas ça parce qu'on a
des fans des cavs sur le tchat avec
nouméa kokoro qui landes afin qu'ils
aient pris ya deux ans maintenant
où on parlait du drive il a ainsi un
drive qui était très linéaire il à coco
y avait pas de variation on est dans le
même style je suis assez déçu de ne pas
avoir plus balle en mains qui attendait
cette création après son retour n 6 et
ouais ouais ouais effectivement lui je
pense qu'aussi il avait essayé avec
l'équipe canadienne ont eu 19 savait pas
marché
avec neymar des houston qui portait
pousse le ballon dans cette équipe on a
vu des laines théorie km au nord de
grande taille on a vu car christ à qui
porte le ballon on a vu du belize qui
est un bon passeur non voilà il se
retrouve avec beaucoup de tirs il ya pas
mal de situations de end of de
démarquage et cetera il ya très peu de
pick and roll statique une équipe qui
bouge bien raisonné assez plaisante et
en plus elle est efficace comme ça
jusqu'à hier soir je te paye pas le
résultat il y avait onze victoires 0
défaite eux ils ont des ils ont des
objectifs de titres donc ils veulent
vendre des prospects ils le font je
pense que ils vont y arriver ils
enverront trois ou quatre mecs en nba
choix les deux trois prochaines années
mais il essaie surtout de gagner des
matches au niveau de la pac twelve donc
voilà peut-être que le projet est
toujours des projets le projet bénédicte
mathurin porteur de balle il n'est pas
compatible avec le fait de gagner des
maillots d'une équipe compétitive
s'ils s'imposent pas que c'est que c'est
pas son profil potentiel en tout cas
c'est pour l'instant il excelle pas là
dedans et donc le coach me fait pas
confiance à prendre un à plein des
joueurs qui je suis personne mais
kentucky
des joueurs qui
qui sont pas mis en valeur en tant que
porteur des balais qui derrière albi
explose et on pense à tout vent qu'elle
soit d'autres contextes lui pour le
compte des revenus qu'avec l'équipe
canadienne n'était pas non plus un un
meneur créateurs en tout cas un premier
porteur de balle de mines ont donc je
suis assez pessimiste sur ce
développement là au niveau supérieur on
va passer la défense maintenant vous me
dites ainsi si je vais trop vite ou si
justement je vais trop lentement et
cetera moi je suis là pour m'adapter à
vous aussi
défensivement joueur extrêmement
frustrant comme nous le disait ben dans
son article comme nous le disait julien
aussi il ya des très bonnes choses
notamment ici en agressivité sur l'homme
alors je vous le remet depuis le début
on essaie de se mettre en plein écran
il est là notre ami
et là je mets de la pression sur
santiago vescovi je reste bien nos
contacts je vais mettre des mains vous
voyez comment je suis une petite peste
je bouge bien au niveau des pieds et je
vais les obliger à casser la taca
revenir en arrière j'ai fait perdre 10
contre la possession on se remet au
ralenti
regardez comment les mains elles sont
actives et comment on va tout de suite
lui monte aux corps besco vit cette
année sa chute heures quasiment exclusif
ipar peloton bref qu'avant je lui monte
dessus je mets de la pression regarder
les mains comment elles sont actives les
pieds aussi je bouge bien je casse les
angles de passes des deux provoqué
d'interception
je casse la tacc en place avec le
démarquage ici et je suis bien placé ça
c'est ce qu'on aime beaucoup voir chez
bénédicte mature annoncé le potentiel
pour être une teigne vraiment une tête
défensive athlétique et rentrer dans ton
corps dans ta tête
maintenant la réalité est assez autres
je vais essayer de trouver une autre
bonne défense quand même parce que je
pars poser en un constat trop négatif
encore en agressivité ou puisqu'à ici
alors
on slam à vitesse réelle pour commencer
il est là
ah bah non c'est encore ça négatif
combat les voilà l'équipe ont vraiment
buggé alors ça ce que j'aime pas chez
des patients on va repartir natation pas
non plus
on va pas chercher de midi à quatorze
heures donc et un rebond offensif il
était de la partie en transition il
jouait la carotte
il va revenir il va communiquer en
disant prends celui là bas sauf que
c'est trop tard il y va aussi il ya un
trou et ça fait 1 3 point heureusement
trop point qui n'est pas qui ne
sanctionne pas la défense d'arizona mais
il ya ce problème de manque de
communication très souvent de
où il est perdu sur le terrain il sait
pas quel jour il doit prendre il indique
à ses coéquipiers de prendre un gars et
finalement il y va aussi donc voilà il
est sur courant alternatif notamment
dans la défense que moins du ballon et
ça provoque très souvent des failles
dans la défense d'arizona
c'est frustrant très frustrant parce
qu'on a un athlète
geste est passé un manque de volonté un
peu on va regarder sur de la défense sur
l'homme il ya aussi un manque de
compréhension du jeu dans la défense qui
a c'est assez gênant et donc ça en nba
sera pas sera pas toléré par une équipe
alors on va essayer d'en avoir un autre
du coup donc si je trouve il a et rance
défensif à trouve cette fois ci sera la
bonne dépense et saint lézin inversée je
vais regarder ça
non on a une belle errances défensives
alors on se la met en vitesse réelle il
est en défense normalement sur santiago
vescovi allait avoir un switch entre
d'alan terrier
et mathurin ou dumas turin doit prendre
justin powell qui est un bon shooteur à
trois points qui jouait l'an dernier du
côté d'auburn était lente et louis
d'apprendre vescovi en tout cas c'est ce
qui semble indiquer
le switch effectué sauf que lui les
faucons concentrés sur le ballon sur le
drive ici il suffit pas ce qui se passe
il a suivi l'escaut vie d'hélène terry
se rend compte de la boulette pour être
poli de mathurin powell est totalement
ouvert à trois points
et safra ficelles je vous le mets sans
casser l'action à vitesse ou leur
vitesse réelle alors en vitesse réelle
j'ai dit on n'est pas des mutants
et trois points et un city pointe en
disant bah oui j'aime bien à la fin bah
oui qu'est ce qu'un homme alors on a dit
ah je suis pas bon
regardez ici le geste il tend le bras
pourquoi est ce que t'es pas là parce
que tu as passé vite accro si tu étais
pas concentré tout simplement tout
simplement donc au ralenti une dernière
fois
voilà
je vais un peu long terme parce que je
suis vraiment pas sympa avec lui tout
tout tout tout tout tout tout sur
une deux un driver alors voilà ici on va
être sûr de l'homme homme qui va être
passé sur un premier paquet pas pour ton
explosif il est là
et tout de suite sur un premier pas il
est passé alors il rattrape bien parce
que le portant de balle adverse est pas
un athlète vous voyez encore notre
chorale nos centrales à colorado c'est
pas une grande équipe vous avez un
meneur sérieux mais pas de niveau nba
qui va se faire passer parce qu'au
niveau d appuyer pas confondre est donc
là au niveau de la prise d'appuyer pas
il n'est pas bien
il se fait prendre sur le premier pas
changement de direction il est battu et
une bonne aide d'omar ba l'eau donc
là-dessus pivot via bien aidé nos plus
ça lui permet de rattraper et derrière
au niveau de la cotisation c'est pas mal
mais il est passé donc là dessus moi
j'attends pour un athlète de ce calibre
là avec une mobilité comme il peut la
voir on le voit en attaque latéralement
et dans le dans laxe panier panier bien
mieux que ça a c'est vraiment un manque
de rigueur
manque de rigueur défensive donc battu
sur pick'n roll
ici
donc là on est face à la même équipe
yapi tienne rôle y voit à l'écran vous
avez vu les poils écran et il fait
prendre dans l'écran il court pas
derrière
il est pris il est battu tout simplement
je vous la remet au ralenti il voit à
l'écran regardez à ses yeux j'essaie de
mettre en plein écran
je pense que balou bahlul annonce
regarde les de la tête se tourne
il oriente
et il se fait prendre ici et là des au
niveau de la gestuelle
l'impression qu'il en bout de souffle en
bout de course
et y conteste pas le tir et s'est fêlé
voilà ça c'est pour deux choses qu'on
veut pas voir de la porte de nature un
convoi encore une fois une à deux fois
par nos matchs minimum
autre problème il va sur anticipées
nokia de la bonne volonté mais dans la
réalisation c'est pas bon donc on se
mouille vitesse réelle plein écran
il est là dans le corner gauche il va
sur anticipées ils nous remontent et il
va faire prendre dans le dos tout
simplement
alors banon puisque c'est pas le bon
clip alors bon bah voilà vous avez le
droit à un drive main droite voilà ça
c'est la finition peut pas refaire
pareil c'est pas grave
enfin premiers pas de règles ou droitier
tard me voilà ça c'est le genre de
choses que j'aime pour laquelle
j'aimerais bien voir mathurin en nba on
attaque manque de rigueur au manque de
cui défensif là c'est mon grand qui
vient réclamer à manger à leurs bébés
coeur tu vas sortir de la pièce papa il
est en train d'en garder du film deux
joueurs tu peux dire bonjour si tu veux
[Musique]
et après tu t'en vas
donc excuse moi donc de cui défensif où
le manque de rigueur la différence et
pas évidentes je pense qu'il ya un
manque de rigueur sur le genre l'homme
on voit que des fois il est pas
concentré qui pense qu'il ya de la marge
en fait non et il ya un manque de cui
défensive dans la rotation en tout cas
de manque de communication
rien dit rattrapable parce qu'on y met
de la bonne volonté sur plusieurs
actions mais falloir corriger parce que
je suis ratée en nba si tu étais enfant
première année c'était rookie que tu
défends pas et que tu es là juste pour
de l'attaquant fait on trouvera mieux
que toi donc on ne nous fera pas jouer
on va lui falloir qu'ils corrigent pas
assez rapide moon à plein des joueurs
qui sont très jeunes qui ont du
potentiel défensif et son frustrant je
pense à cameron rédige qui est un
excellent potentiel défensif et qui peut
faire défendre n'importe quoi
du coup je vais essayer de retrouver le
clip que je voulais vous montrer
qu'est ce que ça doit être celui là du
coup ci me leysen inversée sinon tant
pis on passera sur autre chose
ouais c'est celui-là ok bon bah on se
retrouve en fait avec les donc là il va
sur anticiper une remontée et il va se
faire prendre dans son dos tout
simplement ça voilà c'est un joueur qui
a de la bonne volonté qui a appris par
coeur à reconnaître des choses et qui se
fait avoir parce que c'est pas c'est
trop mécanique s'est passé dans le
réflexe donc on stars fait là
il est là
il anticipe la montée il fait prendre
dans le dos et il est battu tout
simplement donc ça c'est quelque chose
qu'on peut avoir
alors
bannon la voûte cliquez pas sur le lien
de sa m je vais le bannir hop là je sais
pas ce que c'est que ce truc là c'est un
faucon nous vous cliquez pas excusez moi
pour ça est-ce que je peux bannir ce
truc là
quand je peux cliquer dessus
là j'ai pas de modérateur avec moi nous
va surtout vous cliquez pas de suivi
puis je le je supprimerai je bannirai
dès que je pourrai désolé
hop là vous suivez le night bottes qui
vous dit qui vous dit faut pas faire
confiance
tout tout tout tout ben voilà allez on
va quand même se faire c'est intéressant
dans la jota défense ipaq mon deuxième
temps donc c'est très rapide ça va très
vite au pis si c'est un joueur qui peut
voir contre a bien compris des des
choses très mécanique comme je voulais
dit il est là il voit karine eux
qui les bat dessus et dont on va aller
surcompensé ôta défensive ici tout de
suite je viens cassé alors qu'ils
avaient plus de défenseur direct pour
venir contester donc ça c'est bien voila
voila c'était le profil de baignade sur
un an je vais vous remettre la liste de
lecture
tournée j'ai plus grand chose d'autre à
vous montrer comme ça et deep mathur ans
et puis on peut en parler si vous avez
envie sur le chat pendant que moi je
fais un tweet pour dire aux gens qu'il
est toujours en live
dites moi du coup voilà ce que vous en
pensez ou est-ce que vous l'achetez moi
je les fins de loterie
enfin notre importe quoi je les milieux
de milieux fin de premier tour pour
l'instant voilà il va il a stagné je
pense qu'ils fassent entre 20 et 30 j'ai
fait pas du tout le porteur de balle
même secondaires l'achète le finissant
d'action j'achète l'athlète cette lettre
voilà c'est ça que je veux que je vais
avoir et je pense que en sortie de banc
au début il peut être intéressant et à
terme devenir devenir pourquoi pas un
titulaire est bien dans une équipe qui
va manquer de juillet le biais de
jeunesse type alors que justin est une
audi quoi dallas mais puis sur l'autre
parfait alors charlotte s'est déjà s'est
déjà chargé mais pourquoi pas dallas
memphis très très bien ouais on voit ce
que fait des semaines et des semaines
ben ça peut être l'idéal pour lui les
knicks pour y penser les knicks pour y
penser vu que les knicks ont décidé de
ne pas donner le ballon et evan fournier
dans ses mots après je suis pas expert
knicks donc je vais parler de ce que je
connais uniquement mais dans un rôle où
et voilà de souilhe ndi qui peut qui
peut couper au panier qui peut mettre
des points qui peut prendre des tirs à
trois points ça intéressant toutes les
équipes qui ont déjà
soit un bond un bon meneur et un ailier
qui porte la balle et qui ont besoin de
d'un joueur comme ça de finition ça peut
être sympa
si on veut du poteau c'est le porteur de
balle je préfère tous les jours un
kendall brawn ou à patrick baldwin alors
tu m'as donné deux exemples opposé pour
moi dans mon coeur j'ai kendall brawn
qui est un ailier dans lequel je crois
en vous et vous quel je crois pour un
développement balle en main et patrick
baldwin pour moi c'est un simple fera
trois points mais ce sera tout moi c'est
un joueur de pick and pop patrick
baldwin et on en reparlera une autre
fois et je crois pas du tout dans le
dans le hand held ce mec là je crois pas
du tout dans le dans la polyvalence dans
l'athlète c'est un jour que
personnellement j'ai pour loterie alors
qu'il est très très coté donc
je serai pas son plus grand défenseur en
plus si envergure c'est moi qui me tape
la ligue horizons l'ami de meilleurs
horizons dans laquelle baldwin évolué du
côté de
milwaukee
je me fais tous ses matches et je peux
vous dire que c'est pas du plaisir là
j'ai regardé en me lauvaux qui rhodes
island a pas très longtemps il me fait
un sur huit
1 sur 8 aux tirs froid qui fini à 6
points alors que c'est le seul joueur
correct de son équipe oeuf je suis très
inquiet pour patrick ballerines
personnellement je suis une équipe que
dans le potentiel j'y vais pas mais on
fera son procès une autre fois et on
invitera à l'âne qui est bien plus
optimiste que moi pour défendre le
pauvre patrick balwin je fais le petit
tweet et on va passer à la deuxième
partie de ce stream je vous ai proposé
un petit jeu un petit quizz tout
simplement on va pouvoir le faire
ensemble et puis je la pole et pour les
commentaires avant de de vous laisser
pour la pause la pose du réveillon
un peu las le switch envergure
tiens si vous voulez dans le chat vous
pouvez peut-être je vous ai mis des
commandes ont regardé si ça marche des
trucs trop tout bête mais le
sommes
voyez si je fais ça qu'on veut si vous
faites ça le point d'exclamation que
plus tard vous avez directement par le
night bottes notre
notre notre lien twitter
paraît si vous faites avec site vous
avez le lien envergure alors je mets le
lien ici j'arrive pas à faire deux
choses en même temps au grand dam
de ma chère et tendre
hop là ouais est ce que ça marche chez
toi est ce que mon ait bâti fonctionne
il n'y a que pour moi qui fonctionne
sheetrit fonctionne pas de saint jo
bizarre peut-être que tu l'as de ton
côté tu me dis hein si ça marche ou pas
moi je le vois pas pareil si vous voulez
pour notre site vous avez leur envergure
peut-être qu'il faut à coup d'oeil les
droits et enfin
si vous voulez je crois avoir
voilà si vous voulez avoir le compte
perso de la personne qui anime le lève
donc là c'est moi
vous avez le compte twitter qui apparaît
directement dans les dents le chat est
con ce sera là nous mettra lan
évidemment nous voilà des petites des
petites des petits outils comme ça des
petits
de petits trucs que j'apprends à faire
peut-être qu'un jour on aura quelque
chose de vraiment qualitatif du côté
d'envergure
quand est ce qu'on va dévoiler nos big
board alors écoute je peux pas de tout
ce pôle et sache que tu les auras
normalement d'ici 2022 avant 2022 on va
avoir les 'big board' de certains
manquent d'envergure qui voile dévoilé
notamment le mignan et ce sera ce sera
avec un ris ville en live cette fois ci
sera pas avec moi ce sera pierre pierre
migaud qui anime je vois youtube et qui
le spécialiste ès ici chi
chi le comment dire qu il le gère et
donc voilà ce sera ce sera fait bientôt
avant le avant le 31 est est resté
informé et va y avoir les tweets qui
font tomber
et puis et puis voilà mes mais très hâte
de vous partager sa voix que ça va être
un super live est forcément aux rives
ils ont ri ville tous les noms donc sa
cote est un petit peu calendrier de
l'avent noël c'est assez cool
tout kouadjo pas de souci je vois que ça
n'a pas marché donc le nay de boîte
s'est pas encore maîtrisé je ferai dans
les commandes s'il faut faire quelque
chose pour pour que tout le monde puisse
à utiliser la commande ça marchera la
prochaine fois un avis sur qui gagnent
murray dans les dernières heures au
cabba écoute sites étaient là pour notre
premier live et aurait pu voir du clip
de kylie ann murray non je plaisante
mais on a on l'a fait en live le
décryptage de keegan murray mais à
l'époque j'étais encore moins bon que
maintenant saisir on n'avait pas
enregistré par des tocards le les
replays automatique donc cela il est
perdu dans les abîmes de twitch et
keegan meurent on a fait se profile en
live c'est un poste 3-4 pour moi 4
exclusivement une bille est peut-être
petit 5 qui a un vrai tir à trois points
qui peut être une option picken pop qui
peut être bien sûr transition qui est un
athlète à ses moyens ça peut être il
peut finir un jour dès l'aube ils
profiteront des deux ne connaît pas donc
le show du jour du terre à terre mais
qui me va pas monter très haut qui a
beaucoup de responsabilités balle en
main du côté de l'iowa cette année mais
qui devrait pas avoir de billet parce
que le dribbler passer assez fluide le
point bas est passé puissant pour
exister en nba six toiles comparer c'est
une sorte de hobby copine mais sans le
jump de démentiel donc voilà un joueur
intéressant que je peux aller drafté sur
une fin de premier tour
qui défensives moins concentré mais qui
va manquer de qualité latéral pour
pouvoir tenir des extérieurs nba dans
une ligue qui switch to moi je suis
assez inquiet pour la cades pour kilian
murray poursuit des extérieurs voilà
quand tu dis quoi thomas je sais pas
trop comment elle est signée par
imposant aux autres alors je t'avoue
cette année on s'est fait kiffer chez
envergure on se fait des big board ne
regarde pas du tout ceux des copains
avant de les sortir moi je sais que j'ai
préparé
alors on avisera ça mais je pense que
dans ma loterie j'ai au moins trois
joueurs que les autres n'auront pas dans
leur top 20 heures 30 j'ai trois joueurs
pour l'instant qui sont sous les radars
et c'est mon côté hipster qui sont sous
les radars et que je vais avoir loterie
donc ce sera assez intéressant de voir
ça et cette année j'essaye alors un
maximum possible de regarder aucune mode
draft d'en garder aucune mode grave de
la part des nba draft nba draft points
et et cetera pour pas me faire
influencer c'est hyper difficile de pas
se faire influencer
et de vraiment regarder tous les matches
possibles alors ce que je fais c'est que
je demande aux copains de me donner les
sans noms de démoc nba draft d'avoir
vraiment les noms n'est pas leur
position et moi ça permet d'avoir des
pistes pour savoir qui je regarde dans
les matches et je regarde trois quatre
matches de cinq équipes de ses cendres
avec l'annoncé fait 300 400 à peu près
matchs minimum et j'essaie de les placer
voilà comment ça va donc s'il ya moyen
que j'ai des écarts assez monumentaux
avec eux avec les autres avec badji top
5 ne l'est pas top 5 n'est pas top 5
j'exige les dents mal loterie pour
l'instant mais je n'ai pas top 5 à 10 il
va être je pense dans mon on regardera
ça plus tard mais il va être dans la fin
fin de ma loterie je pense parce que je
crois en développement et si vous avez
écouté le podcast qu'on a fait sur lui
vous apprenez qu'il a commencé basket à
16 ans et que tous les ans il a
progressé ce qui me fait que je les
jeux les traits aux chamois de ce choix
top-15 pas franchement non il n'y est
pas mais va falloir me justifier très
fort le fait de prendre des pivots
devant lui à falloir va falloir
s'accrocher moi si je veux bien qu'on me
disait mark williams eu c'est mieux
qu'on me dise
je sais pas moussa diabaté que c'est
mieux qu'on me dise est une ride c'est
mieux j'ai plein de contre arguments
voilà donc derrière ça va être hyper
intéressant comme débat est le tien
moitié de choix gelé dans mon top 20
pour l'instant et je pense que c'est
si j'enlève deux ou trois autres pivots
peut-être
delà de la loterie ça peut être mon
premier pivot à l'autre et qui arrive
voilà moussa diabaté très actif on a de
la chance d'avoir ce petit pivot
français donc effectivement moi aussi je
les aime beaucoup et quand on aura assez
de clips de sion fera on fera une
émission champs lui et je pense que
notre façon comme ça en france et y aura
il y aura un podcast évidemment on
parlera de moussa diabaté huit ans sort
de sa grotte au est totalement bah ouais
mais tu verras tu es pas prêt pour mon
board j'ai plein de mecs on va dire qui
donc je suis dans la provocation
on va se passer sur le petit jeu
ensemble on a c'était cool ce petit
moment de discussion là c'est pour ça
aussi que je fais du stream c'est pour
pouvoir la changer avec vous on va
passer aux jeux alors ce que je vous
propose c'est tout comme moi on va se
tester sur on va essayer de voir ça
marche bien voilà on va faire m ça ici
on masse actualiser sa vivacité sur la
draft
2021 alors je vais essayer de vous
mettre le lien
tout on va essayer de faire ça
correctement je vais essayer de vous
mettre le lien dans le chat pour vous le
tester avec moi on essaye de ne pas
tricher
[Musique]
voilà pas besoin de vous le dire mais ça
peu d'intérêt on se référe ans pour
faire ne va pas retrouver les 60 joueurs
qui ont été drafté l'an dernier on a
l'équipe les a draftés je crois que
c'est l'équipe qui avait le pic au début
donc il ya des traits 10 sont pas
indiquées et leurs proches leurs postes
et leurs universités ou quand ils
viennent dans notre pays a écrit l'autre
pays pour blé si vous avez serbie la en
50 et
bien qu'ils y ont joués indique par
exemple ici alors excusez moi j'ai une
de mes peines mes petits qui me fait des
grosses conneries donc je vais le gérer
la chambre immédiatement
mademoiselle tu arrêtes de manger du
carton c'est pas bon pour un chat un peu
là alors je vous mets ça je vous repasse
rapidement parce que ça
sur l'apd est si mal d'envergure ici
les soixante ouanna qui n'ont pas encore
joué en nba tu les oubliez pas forcément
après le but c'est pas c'est pas non
plus enfin si havrais qui fonde c'est
cool moi je vais essayer les 60 quand
même une réputation à tenir mais après
c'est normal de pas tous les connaître
je suis sûr qu'un pas que je vais pas
avoir enfin c'est évident
notamment des européens mais qui n'ont
pas joué que 50 à philadelphia je pense
que j'ai une idée mais parce qu'il a
joué un dossier avant lorsque le spoil
pas dans le chat mais il a forcément que
j'ai oublié alors attendez je visais de
vous trouver le lien sinon vous taper
juste nba draft de 2020 draft quiz sur
sport sport cloud.com j'ai pas trop
comment on le dit à l'ordre qu'on voit
sur la chaîne ici
faut avoir les orthographes aussi oui
voilà après si vous le savez si à la fin
vous l'avez vous savez pas les
accueillir c'est pas grave on s'en fout
enfin le but et c'est juste de se tester
un petit peu alors est ce que peut avoir
le droit de mettre d'avoir mon chat sur
le côté ce serait bien
si vous en trouvez 30 voilà trente c'est
déjà très bien si vous avez déjà la
loterie c'est que vous avez
voilà si vous suivez pas toutes les
équipes nba classique et si enfin
normalement quand on fera des après
l'aller les fans après on fera des plus
vieilles draft et
alors est ce que je peux avoir le chat
nos supplices ans c'est un supplice
ok
incroyable le mât réussi envers son chat
de sa propre chaîne twitch magnifique
pour le félicite
voilà normalement vous avez l'oeil
inquiet tomber on va donner un petit
timer il ya douze minutes
donc je rebascule là dessus
hop alors le live normalement vous
l'avez à l'écran dans les dégoûts laval
écran qu'il apparaît vous avez vu ma
tête 5 secondes avec cette calvitie
magnifique
peuple à écouter ou alors je vais le
faire je vais le dire à voix haute si
vous voulez vous coupez le son vous
couper le son sinon le faire ensemble et
puis et puis voilà alors je vais dire
bêtement je vais taper les joueurs et
puis si vous la regardez en même temps
avec moi on y va donc 3 2 1 c'est parti
alors on essaie de les faire
dans l'ordre elle désolée pour le peu de
qualité c'est un peu fort hop houston
c'est bon cleveland on ne parle que de
lui ces bons florida state mon chouchou
c'est bon gods haga
hockey
le peak 6
d'ailleurs pick six mois j'étais très
surpris un qui tombe aussi haut et
finalement il répond présent donc ça
c'est une bonne nouvelle le pic 8 je
l'avais beaucoup plus bas et il me
il me fait mentir donc très content pour
lui le pic n'est finalement l'équipe de
coeur pic 10
notre pile 10 aulas geagea trou alors
que je ne vois que lui ne voit que lui
parce que je le déteste
tant pis reviendra après je ressens non
il joue au côté de memphis qui contient
aucun problème qui nous en a parlé tout
à l'heure
c'est le premier pic 13 quai
14 golden state on en a parlé aussi ok
j'ai retrouvé le pic 10 excusez moi pour
l'erreur le copain de lebron james celui
qui a été adoubé par lebron james dit
que 15 qui a joué à gonzaga un beau
gosse qui aura nourri porter quoi je
pense à google pilote un beau gosse avec
un tête des reculs
pixels j'espère qu'il va être pas les
accents c'est bon ils sont pas
difficiles le 17 il est peut-être pas
forcément
pardon
pas forcément facile
le kids 17 il ya gilles jamais arrivée à
memphis il a été transféré il a été
transféré
du côté de la louisiane pour vous aider
un petit peu le pic 18
voilà il ya un homonyme qui joue en nba
le pic 19 tout pile 19 qui a été
transférée aussi qui a été transféré
dans une équipe qui est assez chère
aux meilleurs arrières de tous les temps
pour pas créer de débats
le pic fin alors le pic fin qui nous
donne aussi le pic 21 ans des homonymes
deux jours que j'aime beaucoup le pic 22
kg de kentucky haut niveau les lakers
kendrick est qui qui est-ce qui est
tombé beaucoup trop bas encore cette
année du côté de kentucky pour je
retrouverai après c'est pas grave bien
sûr que oui je vois qui s'est en plus
alors il a été changé aussi le pic 22
c'est beaucoup moins paillettes ans il
était du côté des lakers normalement il
est parti du côté d'une franchise qui a
vu grandir
en oiseau un certain oiseaux alors le 24
houston on a fait un petit peu de cases
dessus
y en a un
le 25 houston i gueye
8e puis pas non mais je débute il vient
de houston donc il est plus du côté des
clippers fils est parti dans la capitale
dans la grande pomme le 26 sept journaux
le plus stylé de toute la draft sans
aucune discussion
le 27 c'est mon chouchou et moi j'avais
loterie top 10 et que je pense qu'ils
pourraient devenir all stars le 28
29 phoenix north carolina phoenix north
carolina ah bah bien sûr
évidemment
le 30 cp convenait pas facile par le 30
il vient d'espagne
c'est pas un pic évident le pic 30 le 31
milo qui
nous ont pris non ah oui
forcément le van den de villanova
et ils sont sympas je peux l'abrégé
le 34 alors qu'ils jouent pas au cas ici
là des transféré du côté de new york si
jamais vous le cherchez un lituanien du
côté de new york 35 moment-là trouvé par
un homonyme le 36 il était prévu au
qu'ici et il a été transféré lui aussi à
new york dans cet échange là qui a
renvoyé le pic 18
37 o'byrne o'byrne o'byrne des tigers
alors qui est parti du côté de chez
power
notes qu'ils ont envoyée à messi bien
sûr the mighty one 38 chicago new
mombasa c'est le produit local
utah state alors utah state normalement
vous l'avez parce que
un pivot était le premier de sa
de sa de sa nationalité a joué en nba
nous a été un événement le 40 du côté de
baylor qui a chuté à cause d'un problème
cardiaque le 41 aux spurs qui a été
ailier donc c'est notre ami je vais
avoir oublié encore une fois son nom non
c'est bon
ok il me reste 1040 j'accélère un petit
peu et sf michigan
on en a besoin pour les fêtes
ici donc le 43e et transféré du côté de
portland le 44 qui est bien resté à
brooklyn et qui a pu jouer on avait fait
un peu caste si vous l'avez pas vu
c'était très intéressant avec julien epn
entre autres un français qui va jouer à
boston qui vous a joué ce soir
d'ailleurs que j'ai eu la chance de voir
en vrai aux côtés du côté du paris
basket
à 46 autres amis ici le 47 c'est un
homonyme louisville
du côté d'atlanta un style
ici vous avez le beau frère de michael
carter williams si vous l'avez de 49 du
côté brooklyn je sais pas s'ils jouent
là-bas le 50 alors il a fait deux ans
une cia il est revenu
on va en coûter une méga l'ex en serbie
il est revenu en prend une bille est
toc toc tout de même 10 51 kentucky même
vie 51 kentucky arrière je reviendrai
plus tard
ensuite western kentucky
ici si town hall au ralenti allons faire
la faire ça aussi les prénoms géorgien
marineland les tox hockey ici flo rida
c'est lui florida state s'est
lui annoncer le florida state
moi j'ai pas le retrouver le grèce
restent non c'est pas lui
adacore l'étoile c'est l'hommage du
joueur qui est décédé malheureusement
qui est attendue au premier tour
le regard de kentucky six points
derrière saint hélier voilà donc les
toiles si vous trouvez pas il ya but
almost effet après la loterie
florida state florida state j'ai pas
l'avoir texas ici c'est rami libre dans
sa tête
le grec je ne trouverai pas c'est clair
et net je l'aurais pas alors il a fait
ça me fait iech comme on dit parce que
c'est ma franchise préférée de ace ici
c'est le gros là
vous me dîtes si vous l'avez le 57
charlotte
mais je crois pas qu'ils jouent à
charlotte du coup aujourd'hui le
transférer
comment il s'appelle
je crois que c'est le numéro 10 mais
j'suis pas sûr
j'ai pas l'autre je suis bloqué à 23 le
23 le 23 ce que je peux cet été les 23
espagnols il a joué à la coupe du monde
donc voila et le 24 on en a fait un buzz
cast avec julien si les fans de james
harden il a pris son numéro arizona
state
si ça peut aider
je tombe ça mais c'est pas ça non
comment il s'appelle g que lui en plus
j'ai que lui
eux
ils restent trop 1014 donc écoute meneur
des clips mobile 33 ah j'oubliais
33me à merci aux ouailles au oui oui
c'est la belle histoire des bobcats
ok merci effectivement
alors
atteint à 23 ans tout bas c'est déjà
bien 23 55 c'est bien aussi
alors alors alors alors alors qui sait
peut être
ah mais je suis trop coup
moi je cherchais un américain mais
complètement oublié dans qui joue bien
du côté de charlotte et le 60 l'aurait
pas le 60 je l'aurais pas
sa 100ème là le grec
je peux pas donc je m'avoue vaincu je
vous laisse je laisse le temps pour
terminer vous
donc je ne ris 60 ça aurait fait une
belle draft mais je n'allais pas notre
âme y dîne diana là
il a un nom en même temps le boulou est
le j'ai pas le spoiler pour ceux qui
l'ont pas vu mais sincèrement je crois
il a hélas partait à la fin de l'année
et c'est donc
je me suis fait tout l'équipement en
revue mais je les regardais pas très
longtemps envie c'est de savoir qui
restent encore
et donc
et donc les tombes écouter de charlot t
il on voudra fait énormément de joueurs
charlotte donc voilà j'ai fait 45
taboga sur springer sinon tu avais tout
premier tour bat bien joué déjà bien
joué jaden springer qui est parti jouer
du côté de tennessee avec eux j'ai pas
moi je peux donner allez tiens johnson
qui a été drafté aussi à tennessee ils
étaient tous les doigts tendus de plus
hommage à michael jackson dans ma
l'autriche je l'avais en 8es springer
dans le parti 20 30
qui me frustre a pas joué springer ben
ouais bah après problème de diane kruger
ou est ce qu'ils jouent il a été drafté
où le jazz dance ringer à côté d'eux de
feeling on sait que c'est pas un meneur
de jeu en fait pour moi c'est pas
aujourd'hui la part la capacité à mener
le haka amener le ballon a créé à passer
pour les autres donc donc je comprends
pourquoi il joue pas
mal hein as défenseur assez intéressant
mais
mais moi je l'avais j'y croyais pas dans
ce projet de la tène springer là où
beaucoup d'autres étaient bien plus
optimiste
59 ici bas c'est déjà très très bien le
6 mai les ouailles a pas beaucoup de
route kitty jours pour regarder la seule
qui jouer et faire un petit bilan alors
moi j'ai mon stream qui a planté sur le
retour ici donc je vais juste
l'actualiser si vous avez le sont
excusés mois en doublant dans c'est bon
je voudrais récupérer ou pas ouais je
vous ai récupéré une à 15 secondes de
décalage
alors c'était qu'il y ait là il reste
cinq secondes je vais pouvoir apprendre
ça tape à give up never give up comme
dirait
notre 35
alors comment il s'appelait
jour juusqu'à lights acquise bon bah
voilà mon bas aucun regret je ne sais
pas qui tu es donc de genre de choses
khaled sa guise à qui je souhaite est
forcément le meilleur je sais pas si
c'est à l'intérieur sinon c'est un
ailier bombe a alors vite manqué quito
maxxo creil murphy ouais tu côté de dire
dinia qui était monté en flèche à la fin
kyle jones keith jones que moi j'avais
11e à charlotte et finalement ils l'ont
récupéré avec un trade donc j'y crois
très fort dans ce joueur c'est un
intérieur très mobiles qui peut aussi
dribbler un mélange de yanis et de et de
bam adebayo j'aime beaucoup j'y crois
très fort mais valoir ses pieds sur
christopher donc voilà arizona state
fans de orden qu'il a cette année dans
un poste un rôle de finisseur wenting
rhymes qui joue du côté de new york qui
venait de kansas qui avait été suspendu
pour un problème eu
un problème judiciaire il a évidemment
il s'était pas bien passé il y avait
transféré à houston un joueur qui a des
gros problèmes d'anxiété la shon island
bones à landes qui était à vie s'ils
louent un plein d'orgueil qui est
explosif et qui crache tout que voilà
après jour depuis les grandes et deron
sharp le pivot
la piste vraiment le le mètre cube de
you and see
que voilà un thème essentiel damas vrai
bien jouer sainteté aldama paraît pas
évident un petit qu il avait déjà fait
le coup il ya un an
de loyer en de récupérer le pitre
antilles avait pris des semaines berne
et là ils l'ont refait donc sont à damas
que je connais pas je vais pas
m'inventer une vie c'est un joueur que
j'ai pas du tout suivi qui jouent en
europe donc c'est pas mon terrain
d'expertisé ci peut avoir un terrain tu
expertise donc voilà c'est un joueur que
je connais pas sur dix une autre
commence à être culé 2021
impossible comme question de situation
je ne suis pas mouillée mais je viens
beaucoup cette draft je pense qu'il ya
des potentiels du all-star ya pas mal de
potentiel de all star il ya des jours
générationnel avec ed avec ben barnes
avec mobilis dans cet ordre là c'est
volontaire il ya des pour moi des
possibles all-star des pépites plus loin
joe johnson j'y crois fort terry
johnsson j'y crois fort aussi chengguan
cameron thomass donc voilà il ya des
joueurs j'ai l'habitude cette draft pour
l'instant qui auront la draft et les
joueurs pour ce qu'ils étaient et ça
j'aime bien quand on fait pas d'erreur
de profil j'espère que james bucknall
très peu d'idées comme un créateur
et de ce prime aux non plus mais sinon
j'aime beaucoup pour que les équipes ont
drafté des joueurs pour la bonne raison
à mes yeux est la prochaine grosse draft
2000 23 ans est rien j'avoue que moi
j'ai fait déjà un an d'avancé je me
projette pas comme certains le font chez
nous à l'âne entre autres
pour les drafts lite on fait des parties
sur les mecs 2022 2023 2024 et tout ça
moi je relâche et je connais quelques
joueurs ou une banda base coûte anderson
est maudit bates et ça me suffit donc
c'est pas moi qui pourrait répondre à ça
ils font saliver sarah yayi ils font
honte moi je le draft un jeu le draft et
même feinte de remise en jeu drafté
parce que c'est un saint une encre
défensive incroyable athlète de vous et
c'est un bosseur olivier sarr jeu drafté
pas du tout parce que ça un pivot face
au panier et la passion si tôt mais dans
une équipe de kentucky dégueulasse donc
pas de bol pour lui et joël à yayi qui a
un souviennent du bon bah voilà qu'on
parle et à l'heure de de notre ami
bénédicte mathurin pour je vois ça pour
bénédicte mature enfin zhuhai animé en
plus explosive en pratique avec un peu
plus de potentiel et à l'e10 pourrait
trouver une place en nba j'espère que
cette journée qui sont d'occasion qui
pour y aller est ce que le top 3 de la
prochaine draft est déjà grave et non
non non rien n'est grave et surtout pour
moi qui ai
donc je vais pas me spolier mam on board
qui va tomber dedans dans les dix jours
qui suivent mais j'ai le 3 et le 4 sont
assez interchangeable chez moi et le 5
aussi ça peut être dans la discussion
donc j'ai mon 1 2 qui est le 1 2 assez
classique devant avec nos amis tchèques
et polonais wang héros et après trois
quatre cinq ça peut ça peut bouger et
j'ai même vu sur twitter des mecs qui
soulignait qu' on qui n'ont pas le même
top 3 donc ça peut changer ça peut
changer voilà bon bah écoutez c'était
hyper sympa ce petit cousin fort fera
d'autres de ce style là avec le d'autres
cuvées ou des choses comme ça et
j'espère que ça vous a plu moi je vais
arrêter là ce live c'était vraiment
hyper cool mais c'est l'heure d'aller se
reposer parce que demain on a un gros
réveillon qui nous attend on va falloir
pouvoir digérer et avoir un bon
foie est ce que ma blague avec les eyal
diverses vagues et va capoter parce que
je trouve pas le mec je suis pas vont
exactement voilà alors avoir un bon fois
excellent puis ben ben ma voie qui part
en freestyle aussi merci de m'avoir
suivi mètres de nous avoir suivis merci
d'avoir été là j'ai passé un excellent
comme d'hab quand je stream avec vous
c'était vraiment cool on se retrouve
tout bientôt cette fois ci c'est pour de
vrai on se revoit après les fait passer
un bon réveillon profiter de vos proches
prenez soin de vous surtout et puis on
se dit à tout bientôt sur twitter / /
twitch sur youtube je fais des bisous
bye bye et à la prochaine bonne soirée
de gars
et mon chat qui sont qui est onctueux sa
part fait d'aimer d'incroyables bisous à
tous ça